[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild
august 1965 eine warme Sommernacht im
Duisburger Stadtteil Großenbaum ein
junges Paar knutscht wild in einem VW
Käfer herum hier fühlen sich die beiden
ungestört als irgendwo zu Hause bei den
Eltern aber während es im Innenraum des
Wagens zur Sache geht schleicht jemand
um den Käfer herum
sticht einen Reifen auf der jetzt laut
zischt das Paar steckt auf doch da wird
schon die Tür aufgerissen der Mann
richtet sich auf und verlässt das
Fahrzeug wie wild sticht der Unbekannte
im Dunkeln auf ihn ein dann flüchtet er
die Frau dir Freund entkommen mit dem
Wagen aber später stirbt ihr Freund an
den Verletzungen
[Musik]
was für eine Horrorszene willkommen zu
einer neuen Folge unseres täglichen
Podcast ich bin Stefan Netze Band und
ich bin Mirko Kasimir und das ist ein
Fall der empfindliche Hörer verstören
kann deshalb weisen wir gleich am Anfang
darauf hin dass in dieser Geschichte
sehr drastische todeszenen geschildert
werden wer darauf sensibel reagiert der
sollte diese Folge lieber auslassen
die Begebenheit am Anfang gehört zu
einer Mordserie die schon mehr als zehn
Jahre zuvor begonnen hat und die weitere
11 Jahre später noch viel unfassbarer
enden wird über dieses Ende sagt ein
Kommissar später das werde ich nie
vergessen wie wir die Tür vom
Kühlschrank aufgemacht haben und dann
stand da der Kopf des Mädchens
unten auf dem Kühlschrank Boden stand
Marion's Kopf mit zwei großen braunen
Augen die einen angucken wenn man die
Tür aufmachte
wir berichten heute von Joachim Kroll
der als Ruhe Kannibale in die deutsche
Kriminalgeschichte eingegangen ist
Joachim Georg Kroll wird 1933 als
sechstes von 9 Kindern in eine
Bergarbeiterfamilie geboren die Kreuz
Leben in der oberschlesischen Stadt
Hindenburg Joachim geht von Anfang an
als schwächlich und nicht besonders
schlau er geht nur fünf Jahre zur Schule
der Vater erzieht die Kinder mit harter
Hand was nichts anderes ist als eine
Floskel für familiäre Gewalt den dealen
Joachim der kaum lesen kann trifft es
besonders oft nach der kurzen Schulzeit
muss er auf Bauernhöfen als Tagelöhner
arbeiten und hier biegt er schon falsch
ab seine ersten sexuellen Erregungen
spürt Kroll wenn Kühe und Schweine
geschlachtet werden
er beginnt sich in Stelle zu schleichen
und sich an den Tieren zu vergehen auch
die Körper geschlachteter Tiere benutzt
er um sich zu befriedigen noch während
der Vater in Kriegsgefangenschaft ist
sieht die Familie nach
Nordrhein-Westfalen hier arbeitet
Joachim Mahl als Toilettenreiniger mal
als Hilfskraft im Bergbau
1955 stirbt seine Mutter und das ist
sicher kein Zufall dass er in genau
dieser Zeit seinen ersten Mord begeht
nach allem was man heute weiß ist dieser
allererste Mord nicht geplant vielmehr
versuchen sich Joachim damals gerade 22
Jahre alt und eine junge Frau namens
Irmgard Strehl Auswahl der der an
einvernehmlichem Sex
aber Joachim kommt zunächst nicht zum
Höhepunkt und rastet aus er ersticht
Irmgard verstümmelt ihren Körper und
vergeht sich an der Leiche der
entstellte Körper wird in Lüdinghausen
im Kreis Coesfeld gefunden ein Monster
ist geboren dem geistig
zurückgebliebenen Joachim Kroll stehen
in seinem Berufsalltag hier in
Nordrhein-Westfalen keine geschlachteten
Tiere mehr zur Verfügung aber er hat
jetzt herausgefunden wie es ihnen erregt
wenn er Menschen zu seinen Opfern macht
1956 wird in Kirchhellen heute ein Teil
von Bottrop ein 12-jähriges Mädchen
vergewaltigt oder mordet die
Ermittlungen führen ins Lehrer im Juli
1959 eskaliert Kreuz gewalthunger weiter
im Stadtpark von Essen vergewaltigt und
er wirkte er eine 16-Jährige danach
schneidet er mit dem Messer Streifen von
ihren Hüften und dem Hintern ab außerdem
verringern sich jetzt die Abstände von
Kreuz Wahnsinns Taten im April 1962
verschwindet aus Burscheid spurlos ein
zwölf Jahre altes Kind wenig später wird
den Dinslaken eine 13-Jährige
vergewaltigt und erwirkt keine zwei
Monate später tötet Kroll in Duisburg
eine 12-Jährige wieder werden Streifen
aus dem Körper geschnitten was genau
geht im Kroll bei all diesen morgen wohl
vor Kommissar Bernd Jägers der Kroll
Jahre später viele Stunden lang verhört
beschreibt Kreuz Drang so call wollte
hauptsächlich das Kribbeln wegbekommen
er suchte seine Opfer völlig wahllos aus
es war ihm irgendwann sogar egal ob sie
in der Nachbarschaft lebten oder nicht
hauptsache er hatte seine Geschichte
erledigt und das Kribbeln war weg
anders als anderen eitlen Serienmördern
ist es Kroll völlig egal wie sein modus
operandi nach außen wirkt laut Kommissar
Jägers geht es ihm nur um seine eigene
Lust ihm war wichtig seine Opfer sterben
zu sehen er wollte beobachten wie sie
die Augen verdrehen wie das Gesicht blau
anliegt je nachdem wie er die Frauen und
Kinder umbrachte das erste Mädchen z.B
erstach er andere erdrosselte er mit
ihren Halstüchern und BHs es gab kein
Muster nach dem Kroll agierte darauf
legte er keinen Wert
das sind gruselige und im Rückblick
sicher zutreffende Einschätzung aber in
den Jahren in den Groll wieder und
wieder mordet hat die Polizei überhaupt
keinen Plan im Gegenteil bei insgesamt
vier Morden werden sogar unschuldige
verhaftet einer von ihnen kommt mit
einem richterlichen Schuldspruch ins
Gefängnis mindestens zwei der irrtümlich
Beschuldigten zerbrechen an dieser
Schande und begehen Selbstmord die
Polizei muss man sich schonungslos sagen
versagt jahrelang auf ganzer Linie eine
Schande ehrlich zumal das morgen
weitergeht
1965 kommt es zum dramatischen Überfall
auf das Liebespaar im VW Käfer bei dem
Kroll den Duisburger Hermann Schmitz
versteht
September 66 Frau in Marl erwürgt
Ermittler Verdächtigen fälschlicherweise
ihren Freund Dezember 66 ein
fünfjähriges Mädchen wird vergewaltigt
und in einem See ertränkt mai 170 eine
13-Jährige wird erwirkt ein Unschuldiger
wird festgenommen
1976 ein zehn Jahre altes Mädchen wird
erwürgt
diese Aufzählung wirkt als könnte sie
immer so weitergehen und weitergehen
aber dann kommt der Sommer
1976 er hat eigentlich so schon genug
Drama Potenzial der Sommer 76 ist in
Deutschland einer der heißesten an denen
sich die Menschen erinnern können
wochenlang fällt kein Regen den Bauern
vertrocknet bei 30 Grad und mehr die
Ernte auf den Feldern außerdem herrscht
Terroralarm im Juni entführen Verbrecher
aus Palästina zusammen mit Raf Mördern
ein Flugzeug nach Uganda bei der
versuchten Befreiung sterben mehr als 50
Menschen
Anfang Juli 1976 wird die kleine Marion
Kettner aus der Friesenstraße 3 in
Duisburg Lahr vermisst sie war vorher
mit zwei anderen Mädchen auf den
Spielplatz gegangen da Marion erst vier
Jahre alt ist sucht die Polizei sehr
schnell mit einem groß aufgeboten hier
sogar ein Hubschrauber kommt zum Einsatz
hunderte Polizeibeamte hören sich in der
Nachbarschaft um andere gehen mit
Spürhunden durch die Wohngegend wie sich
später herausstellt wurde Marion zuletzt
mit einem Joachim Kroll aus dem
Nachbarhaus gesehen er gilt als netter
Couch und wird der Liebe Achim genannt
Kommissar Jägers beschreibt ihn später
als das hutzelmännchen das sein linkes
Bein nachzieht als einsamen Spinner mit
dem Mann im Zweifel Mitleid hat während
der Suchaktion ahnt noch niemand von
einem Zusammenhang zwischen Marion
verschwinden und Joachim Kroll aber bei
ihren zahlreichen Nachfragen bei der
Suche von Haus zu Haus fällt den Beamten
etwas anderes auf in der Friesenstraße
11 ist seit Tagen ein Etagenklo
verstopft berichtet ein Mieter sein
Nachbar Joachim Kroll habe ihm gesagt er
habe die Eingeweide eines geschlachteten
Kaninchens herunterspielen wollen die
Polizisten rufen einen Klempner und sie
befragen Kroll
ich habe geschlachtet ein Kaninchen
bestätigt der versehentlich habe ich
wohl mit den Innereien des Klo verstopft
Kroll lässt die Polizisten in seine
Wohnung es wird eine Ortsbegehung des
Grauens in der Tiefkühltruhe liegen
Päckchen mit Menschenfleisch im Kochtopf
auf dem Herd befindet sich eine Brühe
aus Möhren und Kartoffeln sowie eine
kleine Menschenhand
mir kam nur der Gedanke dass man einmal
probieren müsste wie Menschen Fleisch
schmeckt ich habe Hände Füße und Arme in
einen Kochtopf getan mit Wasser begossen
und gekocht ich wollte einmal probieren
wenn das Fleisch geschmeckt hätte dann
hätte ich die ganze Leiche nach und nach
aufgegessen als es aber nicht schmeckte
habe ich es mir anders überlegt
[Musik]
zunächst untersuchen Streifen Beamte den
Tatort und führen erste Befragung durch
vor dem Haus versammeln sich immer mehr
Nachbarn aus der Friesenstraße es
entsteht eine exklusive Stimmung wenn
sie könnten würden die Anwohner den
lieben Achim jetzt wohl München die
Polizei aber schickt die aufgebrachten
Leute nach Hause schließlich übernimmt
Kriminal Obermeister Bernd Jägers den
Fall von dem wir ja bereits am Anfang
dieser Episode gehört haben er ist
damals 27 Jahre alt verheiratet Vater
eines siebenjährigen Sohnes bevor er
kreuz Wohnung betritt haben die Kollegen
ihn natürlich vorgewarnt trotzdem ist es
ein Schock
das werde ich nie vergessen wie wir die
Tür vom Kühlschrank aufgemacht haben und
dann starte der Kopf des Mädchens unten
auf dem Kühlschrank Boden stand Marions
Kopf mit zwei großen braunen Augen die
einen anguckten wenn man die Tür
aufmachte es beginnt tagelange Verhöre
Jägers berichtet später in Interviews
mit dem Fokus und der neuen ruhezeitung
das Kreuz zunächst völlig verschlossen
ist ich merkte dass das ein sehr
zurückgezogener Mensch war der immer
allein war der seine Lebensverhältnisse
war geregelt hatte aber der Tagesablauf
war immer derselbe
dann habe ich mir gedacht wie fängst du
das an dadurch dass er sehr kontaktscheu
und zurückhaltend war dachte ich ich
spreche mit ihm einfach mal über seine
Hobbys sein Leben
Achim merkte dass jetzt mal jemand mit
ihm über seine Probleme seine
Verhältnisse redete
Jägers lockt Kroll also aus der
schmoll-ecke und so gesteht der nicht
nur den unfassbar grausigen Kannibalen
Mord an der vierjährigen Marion sondern
auch schon einige der vorausgegangenen
taten aber er weiß Gedächtnislücken auf
erinnert zum Beispiel die Tatort nicht
mehr genau im Verhör sagt Kroll ich weiß
dass wenn ich da wieder hinkomme ich
euch zeigen kann was ich gemacht habe
und so fahren Kommissar Jägers und sein
Team mit den Serienmörder mögliche
Tatort ab an den Haltepunkten wird er
jeweils gefragt ob ihm irgendwas bekannt
vorkommt dann orientiert er sich an der
Vegetation und findet tatsächlich oft
die Orte
ermorde wieder bei Jägers Ermittlungen
wird nochmal deutlich wie schlicht der
Beschuldigte ist sein IQ beträgt gerade
einmal 76 wenige Tage nach der
Aufklärung des Falls wird die kleine
Marion Kettner in Duisburg Laab
beigesetzt zur Trauerfeier kommen
hunderte para Dietrich Kohr nennt den
Mord die Tat eines vom Teufel Besessenen
Menschen am Freitag dem 5 oktober 1979
beginnt im Saal 201 des Duisburger
Landgerichts der Prozess gegen Joachim
Kroll
nach der Untersuchung von 14 Todesfällen
wirft ihm die Staatsanwaltschaft acht
vollendete Morde und eine versuchte
Tötung vor der Vorsitzende Richter
paul-georg schimmern muss in dem
Verfahren klären ob der geistig
beeinträchtigte Angeklagte überhaupt
schuldfähig ist er muss damit klarkommen
dass Kroll viele seiner
vernehmungsaussagen später widerrufen
hat und er muss sich durch einen ganzen
Wust von morgen und falschen
Verhaftungen kämpfen
es dauert 151 Verhandlungstage bis
schimmern sein Urteil verkündet neunmal
lebenslang der Menschenfresser von
Duisburg die Bestie vom Rhein wandert
buchstäblich für den Rest seines Lebens
ins Gefängnis denn Joachim Kroll stirbt
am 1 Juli 1991 an einem Herzinfarkt in
der JVA Rheinbach und damit sind wir am
Ende unseres heutigen falls wir danken
euch fürs zuhören und freuen uns wenn
ihr auch beim nächsten Mal wieder mit
dabei seid wenn ihr Anregungen Lob
Kritik oder fallvorschläge für uns habt
über die wir hier mal berichten sollen
dann schreibt uns gerne eine E-Mail oder
eine Nachricht bei Instagram die Links
dazu findet ihr in den Show Notes bis
zum nächsten mal euer Mirko und euer
Stefan